as you begin to look into healthcare
analytics
you may find yourself searching for
definitions and differences between
health informatics
bioinformatics and healthcare analytics
it's not hard to see why as the three
disciplines work in similar areas of the
health
computing and i t space but in fact they
are very different and have uniquely
defined roles that complement one
another
health analytics and informatics are
both essential for the success of
healthcare organizations
healthcare organizations must be able to
manage analyze
and interpret data in order to identify
the best ways to deliver high quality
care
although some consider analytics and
informatics to be interchangeable terms
the two are distinctively different in
concept and practice
health informatics is the
interdisciplinary study of the design
development adoption and application of
i.t based innovations in healthcare
services delivery
management and planning in practical
terms
healthcare informatics relates to the
ecosystem of data and systems that
support operational and clinical
workflows rather than the analysis of
data found therein
the diagram depicts the relationship
between the two major domain of health
informatics
health information technology which
focuses on the tools and machines
and health information management
focuses on the organization
and dissemination of information example
of the job scope of a health
informaticist may include
managing ehr integration into clinical
workflows
reduce health disparities engage
patients in families
improve care coordination maintain
privacy of health information
improve access to health information and
improve education and compliance
healthcare analytics on the other hand
refers to analysis of the data to inform
decisions
improve quality and performance of the
health care organization
health data analysts have the advanced
knowledge to acquire
manage analyze interpret and transform
data into accurate
consistent and timely information
example of the job scope of a health
data analyst may include increased
access to care
and decrease costs using business
analytics
overcome reimbursement challenges using
smart algorithm
improve patient outcomes using big data
analytics
optimize resources using descriptive
conduct research using advanced
analytics
improve clinical quality using
operational analytics
and detect fraud using prescriptive and
real-time analytics
another field of prominent importance in
the field of analytics and informatics
is bioinformatics bioinformatics focus
on analysis
interpretation data mining and
integration of heterogeneous omics data
including the genome
transcriptome proteome metabolome
and algorithmic modeling of biological
systems
it has two roles as a technology
bioinfomatics is a powerful technology
to manage
search and analyze big data in life
sciences
as a methodology bioinformatics is a
top-down holistic
data-driven genome-wide and systems
approach that generates new hypotheses
finds new patterns and discovers new
functional elements
it complements traditional experimental
biology methods
a seamless combination of computational
and experimental methods should be the
best way to study a biological question
the bio and bioinformatics signifies the
biological questions it studies
many of which can be grouped under the
conceptual framework from genotype to
phenotype and the central dogma
some examples may help you understand
better
for instance sequence alignment are the
sequences of two genes or proteins
similar
could they be homologous how can we find
the closest homolog of the gene we are
studying from the vast databases
can i use the known function of a known
gene to guide the study of my gene of
interest
given dna and genome sequences how can
we find the genes in the vast genome
how can we compare the similarity and
difference between two whole genomes and
reconstruct the evolutionary history
what are the syntenic regions between
two genomes
how can we identify which genomic
regions are methylated
at the level of rna expression we often
need to find out which genes are
differentially expressed between two
organs or tissues
between tumor and normal tissues or
between two different developmental
stages
at the level of proteins how do you
identify the expressed proteins from
mass spec data
proteins do not exist in a linear form
in nature
instead they are folded into beautiful
three-dimensional structures in nature
how can we predict the three-dimensional
structure of a protein from its sequence
molecules do not exist or function in
isolation
instead they form complex molecular
network
how can we construct protein protein
interaction networks
transcription regulation networks and
metabolic and signaling pathways
what are the dynamic features of these
networks
furthermore with these data and
researches how can we simulate a virtual
cell
last but not least how do you compare
different people's genomes and use
population genetic approaches to compare
the genomes of the ill and the healthy
and identify the gene mutations that
cause diseases
from these examples we can see that
there are many interesting
and important questions in life sciences
that await our bioinformatics
investigation
seeing bioinformatics from another angle
the informatics in bioinformatics
signifies the information
in computational methods to manage
search and analyze the data
the theme runs along the axis from data
to discovery
first the storage index and search of
terabytes to petabytes of big data
require advanced databases
just imagine your laptop probably has
several gigabytes of hard disk
however just one set of our experiments
often generates one or more terabytes
of data which is too large to fit in
your laptop
managing such big data requires advanced
database systems
analysis of noisy big data requires the
development of many algorithms
software tools and web servers these
make up a big portion of bioinformatics
research
a tradition in bioinformatics since the
early days till today has been to make
most algorithms and software open source
this has contributed significantly to
the broader life science research
and had helped to advance bioinformatics
itself as well
with these tools we can do a lot of data
mining to discover new patterns and
phenomena in life science
finally by integration of data and tools
we can build predictive models of
biological systems
as more and more high throughput
technologies are used more and more in
life science
there will continue to be numerous new
opportunities for technology innovation
in bioinformatics
to meet this challenge a new breed of
professional that could collaborate and
communicate with biomedical researchers
clinicians quantitative scientists and
bioethicists
is needed to translate the genomic
knowledge to improve patient outcomes
in summary healthcare analytics health
informatics or bioinformatics are
basically tools transform raw biological
patient and prescription data into
meaningful and useful information used
to enable more effective strategic
tactical operational insights and
decision making
data is now available more digitally as
technical advances have made it easier
to collect and analyze information from
multiple sources the government
regulatory agency and other public
stakeholders have been opening their
vast stores of healthcare knowledge
including data from clinical trials and
information on patients covered under
public registry programs
in parallel pharmaceutical companies
have been aggregating years of research
and development data into medical
databases
while payers and providers have
digitized their patient records in ehr
as healthcare becomes a greater portion
of expenses for employers
public private and patients there is an
increasing focus on analytics to drive
efficiency and value
therefore it is important that the best
data analytics and informatics
professionals collaborate on
transforming the way
data is gathered maintained and analyzed
through technology solutions
healthcare analyst health informaticist
and bioinformatician need to integrate
and collaborate with clinicians and
experts who understand the healthcare
system and use data
analytics and leveraging the strengths
of each profession effectively
working as a team informatics and
analytics professionals are bridging the
gaps and introducing action-oriented
improvement opportunities with the
intention and potential of improving
healthcare safety
quality efficiency and cost of care